[Music]
[Music]
what is up everybody how is it going
happy Wednesday I think it's when Syria
all the days all the days are blurring
together anywho what's good I hope
everyone has been well Persia here and
today we're playing some Streets of Rage
for Streets of Rage 4 and I'm gonna be
playing on my arcade stick action so
uh-huh
time it was actually kind of dusty which
makes me just want to play fighting
games again because why my arcade stick
so dusty
so I literally had to dust it off to try
this out I'm actually really excited to
play it on the arcade stack I'm hoping
to get those arcade vibes from it and I
mean I haven't played it at all though
this is I'm playing it for the first
time right alongside you guys so this
this should be really fun it looks
really good that was actually a
screenshot in the gallery I put it on
there because I liked that song but this
main menu song I'm telling you it's like
all the music so far I've heard has been
pretty legit so what is good hello
everybody and welcome back
what's up Wayne Brandon mystery eternal
Jake Randall loader game reviewed
Mohamed do Sid what is good alright so
yeah you could do a battle mode like
head-to-head against uh friends um but
you can't do anything else I don't think
until you do the story mode so we're
gonna be playing on a so story mode I'm
gonna be playing on story mode I'm gonna
playing the story mode yeah whatever you
guys get it we're doing story stuff um
what kind of stick am I using I am using
the Hori wrap for which is
it's so dusty and dirty I did dust it
off but you know when you put a lot of
fighting games and you play long
sessions you always get this hand sweat
on the arcade stick right under the
stick portion of it and yeah I have that
on mine right now so the official
release date for this I believe is
tomorrow um also before I hop in I just
want to read through these fighting tips
with you guys cuz I glanced at this
earlier and I like oh wow this is
actually gonna be really fun on an
arcade stick because they do have like
like - inputs pretty much like forward
forward and stuff so X his attack a is
jump B is pickup forward B is throw Y is
defensive special beau-word Y is
offensive special and jump y is your air
specials so one it is all the special
things and it makes sense right y
defense but when you're often you will
you know you want to be on the offense
side of things you want to hold forward
so forward y that makes sense and then
jump obviously you're in the air air
special specials drain health but you
can hit enemies to restore it so it's a
little bit of you know a little bit of
gambling so um what is an arcade stick
this is an arcade stick it basically
looks if you ever been to an arcade it's
like that panel of an arcade sorry next
he advanced techniques advanced fighting
tips here hold X for a strong attack
forward forward X is your blitz move
okay I'm gonna try to remember that all
of this cuz it looks simple but I know
once I'm in there and enemies are coming
at me I'm a bit like button switches
what I do anyways forward forward
exploits move back X is the back attack
you know
backhand those fools then we got be
midair grab just be okay because you can
pick stuff up with beam and I guess you
can grab people with beam all right
star move Y and B okay so that's like
with my layout right now that would be
focused attack alright so why am B and
then get close to grab all right forward
X X or back X so X is our throw a jab is
our throw and then a vault so I can get
close and bolt them or get close and
throw them all right
some moves are invincible take advantage
of this alright so the defensive special
is invincible noted so when I get scared
I'm just gonna mash water rock because
why not
okay all right hey be patient guys I
need to absorb this information before
we hop in or else it's gonna be it's
gonna be bad all right
those were our two tips from the game I
feel like I already forgot most of it
but let's hop into the story slot number
100
hold up I am going to play on normal
thank you very much ooh ooh yeah yeah
this music I'm diggin it I'm diggin it
alright so we do have some new
characters and we have some returning
characters so you know blaze is
definitely looking fire right now I
might play her she looks super dope
sherry looks super cool I think she's
the daughter of a character maybe I'm
not sure I heard she was the daughter of
another character is amazing I used her
she has a guitar that means you know am
I gonna hit people with music no that's
like one of my defensive specials gonna
look like I don't know I don't know
we're gonna find out together everyone
looks cool oh he looks like he's a
bionic arm somebody that my beans
- lets I want to try to play all four of
the characters today so let's start with
number one let's start with lure out of
her Jeep rider sheep dad's got some
Laura vibes I'm not on that in line I
press a to start ooh all right let's do
this
ooh ten years have passed since the fall
of mr. X and his syndicate the city has
been at peace until now a new crime
Empire has arisen corrupting everything
good in the city it is rumored to be led
by mr. X's own children the white winds
are detectives axel stone and blaze
fielding join forces with their old
friend's daughter cherry hunter along
with Floyd
Araya an apprentice of the brilliant
doctors on together these four
vigilantes will fight against the Y
syndicate I missed the last of it she's
a bridge oK we've got this the tunes are
so smooth they're so smooth okay so
we're starting with the streets game
volume is low well let me turn that up
all right let me know if that's better
okay so I don't want to test out any of
my wife specials yet because it costs
help fry itself and then jump oh that
was like four necks okay nice nice oh
that's painful I wonder if I can come
out hey hold up
[Music]
and then hold extra Oh got the model
combo okay so that last hit bounces them
away so hey so if we do jab jab oh
they're dead already
jab jab em been for four decks yellow go
in there so and then I can pick things
up
Oh his knife Oh Oh nope though okay that
was forward X which was my throat boom
blue the stylus
[Music]
not playing any games out oh I broke it
okay perfect yeah all right I want to do
some nice stuff though
wanna shank these balls oh okay oh I can
throw it and I didn't throw it
no no okay I'm pretty sure red means I
can't hit that guy like he blinks red oh
[Music]
yeah my invincible move abandoned my
forward one was
[Music]
no I wonder if I could jump over that
[Music]
okay so I honestly the extent I'm about
the time oh just one little jab I wasn't
close enough oh oh I had my back
[Music]
yeah a sense of my sedum up experience
is like the Simpsons March is the homey
he's not invincible
I think that just lets me now he's about
the fusong tried to throw him what is
this
that was overkill but I still very much
enjoyed that okay who's down here this
guy's looking so no who's that hag art
oh no spacing this guy he's out putting
me cut it up I definitely want that yeah
yeah Oh who's got the ring uh okay oh no
see my depth perception is also not that
great Oh packing them down can't touch
this
nah we got the range oh no oh no am i
dead
okay it's all good I have a better idea
of what I'm doing now in theory um oh I
do want to try out some of the other
characters too though
oh let's see she pulls Beryl you can run
with some characters okay okay
oh they started me back to the title
screen yeah respect the place exactly if
only I didn't run out of durability yo
Bob Jones what's good what's good all
right
so Axl was cool yeah we've got Laura
this actually blaze so let's see here oh
oh she's fun don't shoot oh all this is
awesome okay I forgot you could have
hold X to do a stronger move so we'll do
Oh
[Music]
defensive invincible oh okay okay
sound like she said composure he slid
under that really Oh No then he threw me
out of my stream
Oh No
Oh No easy let's cook she's super cold
oh she's just radiating those boss and
I'm waiting from okay to fire from up oh
no oh no oh then I better quick right
that was interesting
[Music]
now yeah all you sidestepped me okay oh
they're hanging out in the sewers I see
that OTG which is super cool take that
the distance Pegman check this knife at
you
[Music]
oh I can still get a juggle after that
[Music]
that was fun Oh Oh No
hey she's cool shoot Oh No I'm solo okay
I tried to do my defensive move and then
okay so forward okay I think I like her
more than Axl so far you know yeah mash
that Oh
oh I drank a sneakin okay it's fine
um there's something else I'm not using
[Music]
okay
now when I got the pipe oh oh oh and I
got one for later
thanks for some flavorings nah no no
hold up Owen I wouldn't take his fight
though I think he has more hits of
durability left on that Michael is there
a guideline son
hold it suplex I can throw any theories
[Music]
yeah this is also kind of reminding the
other threw me out oh no no we're
[Music]
car just sick oh I got it save me
hey yeah Heights oh yeah nah how can I
get some invincibility on my my ax on my
string oh wait no no no no no we want to
retry that I should try another
character actually oh there we go why to
skip thank you thank you this game
release is tomorrow I believe is there
where get help or do I just have to be
godlike and stop being a scrub I forget
it's just Y by itself
[Music]
why what was that little low kick she
did I'm forgetting something here
[Music]
that one what was that oh it's my okay
okay okay
gotcha gotcha gotcha gotcha gotcha that
changes things a little bit can't find
them so money but a girl needs some help
nah get away oh no and then go somewhere
there's a lot of items on the floor
[Music]
it's so if I'm liking this way than I
would have to get aha okay okay yeah I
think maybe um a and X might be he
punched me out of my throat Oh No
[Music]
okay okay he's got me red cool I forgot
I had an air one that was my fault
hey oh dang slide you get over here
okay ding I hit the first guy and then
the second guy straight up shoryuken me
aah I'm invincible let's go hey I'm a
strut my stuff over here yo can't get
some food can I get some roasted chicken
you're a longer younger no stay away
from OHS oh dang oh dang not like
nothing like
oh my goodness smashes telephone oh my
goodness
I shouldn't have look chat I gave
getting to the same spot and dying oh
[Laughter]
they're like hey you need some help you
need some more lives um let me try out
some of the other characters first
although I think so far I really do like
her
[Music]
I'm playing on PC but it is also on ps4
for sure for sure or it will be tomorrow
all right let's see what she has okay
here's a jam oh I like that
[Music]
Oh rock on girl she's going out oh wait
oh she can run alright this is already
my type of character heck yeah Oh some
fruit was it so this computer can run
which is already amazing oh wow and it
stores the input so when I press forward
and then X again oh no oh no no
[Music]
nice it's literally like camp session
[Music]
okay so if I wake up with oh I should
have did my Hey no he hit me out of it
[Music]
Oh collection isn't that one instead on
wall bounces - oh I'm gonna see what my
error one is oh it's it's basically home
breaker oh I'm a lot massage and I think
[Music]
I died but that combo was getting really
cool
all right she's dope I really like her
so far telephone yeah chicken thank you
for the for the tips sir oh that is so
cool that combo is dope she's gonna make
this up there
oh I try it to do her special ex before
he split into me which would have been
all right all right there okay so after
this after the area juggle forward
forward X this is surprisingly fun I'm
not gonna lie I'm ready for some more
risk Capcom chuckling I mean oh right
there that's the combo he died I know
Heights OH
[Music]
I could have juggled in from that oh oh
this fall
get away from me no I dropped it yes
it's so instant your bouquet manner
gives me all the food now okay that this
case I forgot about that jam session
he threw me on that
No No
[Music]
I get anything for beating this up
Oh star I have star power I forgot what
the thing was with abyss yes jab session
everything's jam session because she has
guitar fall again with the anti-air
match that special new with
[Music]
oh wow she had like a little cami style
back X or Nica I should say actually it
looks more like our Mika okay wait let
me beat up some of those stuff some hail
oh no it's the quad no goalie that was
an accident
oh you just spawned another one Oh nah
oh okay I shouldn't leave those on the
for event as what you're saying
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
what
[Music]
no purple if why is it so ever me to
line up with him oh my gosh I'm so back
back oh my god oh my god boo boo
nope no someone
I can calm up through the throat
[Music]
okay oh come on you
[Music]
[Music]
yeah we'll finally got the combo for
like the last oh man this character is
legit go down Cossack go to the side did
I add forgot keep this up oh oh I got a
jump in there I didn't even realize it
was a hole who did he's gone five
healing hands in your pockets Do You
Know Who I am
nah we're in
[Music]
Oh into the back X oh oh oh no I was
like wait let me stop being a him and
actually so fun oh yeah he air dared me
I don't believe that for a second
oh crap oh all right sherry I'm sorry
but I've been so bill it I'm using all
my health for that okay I was like he
better not some voices parachuted to
death please I need some chicken or
something in oh yes that is just chicken
oh my cuts I'll fight them in here oh my
god
I like this this camera shot all right
let's go
this is oh she has a gun
oh she's bossing Oh
what all right hold up
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god I cannot know she's called the
homies wait we're good
uh-oh we got me out of there but
oh that was good oh it's gonna be good
no and that hits more than one character
it's so far of the three characters I
tried I think cherry is the best I
haven't tried the other characters yet
but of the three I tried I'm really
feeling hurry now what do you guys think
what do you guys think my Bennet it's
hard to like read the chat and not get
obliterated but I'm also having a ton of
fun with this game yeah cheery is
awesome she is awesome oh it's all
hand-drawn I didn't know that I
mentioned that earlier but yes this is
also gonna be on ps4 I'm playing on PC
right now but it is also gonna be on ps4
[Music]
but yeah okay finally cleared the stage
that was really really fun though and
yeah I'm liking sherry so far snake girl
oh she was pretty crazy
she was pretty crazy oh snap Spidey in
the chat raise your hand if you're
excited for game swap labor oh I'm
excited for play for all it's gonna be
really really cool thank you guys thank
you guys
yes didi I figured out at least one
combo with her so I'm already feeling
more confident you're getting this on
switch nice good stream oh thank you so
much I'm just you know learning this
game I'm having a good time and cherry
is the go oh I know what I can do after
that okay so I can do this
oh and then into the forward forward X
and then I wonder if I could do
oh wait that's a jump I definitely don't
use my jump moves enough
[Music]
poets OSU neither am I supposed to be
that the cops or anything my friends did
I guess uh
oh no they're out for blood they're
taking everyone down oh no you didn't
know
Oh wrong one that was please
is it that kick or do I just run up to
them oh yeah now new old gut-punching
news get out of here
that move is fantastic
[Music]
oh okay me that doesn't work maybe I
could do that
no maybe against the wall
oh look let's just leave them in there
they don't need a comma off but I was
not expecting that
[Music]
oh so the better axe actually did a
little bit of a launching lunch that
might be useful for later who slips on
the chicken yeah I mean you gotta watch
out for that slippery chicken y'all oh
no oh no oh okay
no no I can get a follow-up after that
yeah all right this fool got a shoot so
fans curtain this game it looked like I
am almost okay I was expecting that to
do a lot more damage but I am on normal
soap Oh too fast for you we do better
alright so she's great against this guy
oh hi drops it again
woohoo I can delay it after the air
ducts oh so I can delay the auto combo I
could do a a a wait and then a and still
get the juggle without doing the the
aerial combo that's cool
so there you could be some
[Music]
oh yeah okay I'm gonna try I'm gonna try
together Doug laughter this I'm hurt
there's a green herb right there that
can kill me right oh dang they're just
beating each other up
[Music]
this is really dangerous but we take
those risks
[Music]
all right yeah super damage that's what
I'm talking about
Oh Haggar I'm sorry are you gonna have
to relax while that oh and I would have
been dope ah so we could do oh no I was
trying you know somebody was playing
solitaire over here not working
[Music]
Sherri's news reminds you of Capcom vs.
SNK oh no oh no I'm on my I'm almost on
my last life okay he got me that time I
was trying to abuse the system my class
I am oh no I am NOT getting my forward
oh there we go
[Music]
oh hi Oh
[Music]
all right thank you for patiently
waiting yes
yo Oh No
[Music]
oh he died really fast
[Music]
he'll have one minute punch of help
yeah his shield read rapist I gotta be
careful oh no oh I should just go cuz
that's what that's what's the prawns are
selling me Oh Oh No
just go girl no it's been a once Oh No
this really is Haggai right now no wait
wait wait I kind of need this Oh wasn't
word now we get money real quick
[Music]
nice and steady
oh we out of there
whoa okay I should have just kept trying
to fly away because it is getting me out
[Music]
oh no guys these guys oh oh I have no
help
my gosh all right now tonight oh I'm
still alive I thought that was my last
life I am mashing to my heart's content
Oh too slow this move is so good
[Music]
oh no oh let's go oh they passed the
past you oh okay
our right commissioner
[Music]
can you enter uh oh you know what let me
stop being dumb Oh break that we
straight to jump
[Music]
yo the disrespect Oh
[Music]
oh my gosh real sweaty average right now
no we're sticking this chair here right
now oh no do I have to read you that
whole thing I have literally I'm real
sweaty hours I get the chicken I did get
the chicken I think or was there another
chicken I didn't see I could have swear
I ate one of the chickens but uh when I
ate that chicken at the time my house
was already kind of full so also sorry
but the stream has like a 45 second
stream delay by the way I saw please
keep that in mind if I respond super
late oh crap okay I gotta do this whole
thing in my face all right please beat
up these scrubs real quick
Oh what I was full
[Music]
all right so I can speak and I can do
definite Rab
[Music]
[Music]
okay easy
no I was definitely going for the
cruellest combo guys ever saw
they're really good I was definitely
across
[Music]
Oh y'all still got up after that
[Music]
excellence we're getting we're making
progress and cherry you're right sharing
stuff only my character Oh some
projectile actions
[Music]
well great
I forgot this guy gets an epic intro all
the other guy just disappears all right
you guys already know this track oh yeah
okay try it some boat it's great my
input no I was facing the wrong way
I just come around it's fine it's fine
we upped soundtrack some 800 come on yes
okay and then
doesn't work it doesn't work
[Music]
difficult
[Music]
oh goodness balls no it's like search
kind of on my part but also no missing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is so I wasn't gonna get out of
them how is that surprise throw right
there oh I ran right into it
not like this not like this man
honey get rounding up some chicken Oh No
[Music]
got it
[Music]
Frankie
[Music]
this guy
I remember him from last item Wow pretty
good no I need some chick so I feed me
[Music]
let me in all right fine I'll use that
life up note stuck on that door last
time okay so I know it's a chicken in
the water filter beside you these trades
these women all
[Music]
oh my goodness no way drop the gun
[Music]
Pink's wrong way ow
[Music]
I don't know how to avoid there just no
hope oh no oh my goodness I seriously
don't matter gosh that's okay maybe my
god
[Music]
ouch oh my goodness
[Music]
yeah Wow the combo I don't know
[Music]
come on oh no not like this oh my god I
don't know how holy moley now you even
got your buds with you now
[Music]
you
[Music]
real
you guys battle is stressful
I do not know how I was supposed to
break those throws I rightfully deserved
a horrible ring oh my goodness I am
sweating I couldn't do my beyond my B&B
on that fall I couldn't I didn't know
how to get out of that it's hot it is
hot we need oh it's so open it is it's
too hot in here
the Commissioner has me sweatin holy
crap that was crazy
I should baby I was stressed all right
guys hold up I just need it need two
seconds well barely clutched it out yeah
I can see I'm charging but I tried to
jump over it I couldn't I tried to not
be in his line of sight he's still
grabbed me even if he was like at the
top of the screen and I was at the
bottom so when I slashing all I can do
is like forward for it to get to the
other side but just like besides that I
mean I don't know how else to get past
it aside from doing that but yeah yeah
that's a good Brandon Bivens Thank You
Daniel I'm trying my best
can I try Floyd yeah let me uh let me
try Floyd he's the only one I haven't
tried yet actually oh my goodness this
is fun but like
I'm sweaty and I got this light on me
it's crazy right now it is crazy right
now who the hell are you call me mister
why my dear sister oh I missed it
we've been making quite a mess to be
honest but we're ready to make a very
generous offer to stop all this nonsense
please don't be rash consider it
carefully I don't think they're
considering the he just set our offering
on fire earthers we spent his offering
on fire I don't know I'm still trying to
bring my brain back to the real world
ooh I like the sound of the muffled
sound the track soundtrack I do want to
try river city girls actually Brandon
because I've heard nothing but good
things about that game and I think it
looks really good
just having our chance to play it yeah
alright so now we're using Floyd alright
he's like jacks and Spencer and
[Music]
all right let's see you he doesn't have
a - I don't know how I feel about this
but you definitely hit really hard
[Music]
what is that aperi hole okay oh oh
check them all
all right I'm gonna get to use my
forward forward X I'm just walking for
it's a menacing way oh yeah that was nah
all right what's my invincible
Pina little dad's about to punch this is
amazing nah nah um okay he's pretty fun
I also feel like you might be really
tanky or something
[Music]
and you got one shot in on him
[Music]
yo stop the road it's not rocket punch
that is so dope oh I'm buzzing oh cool
[Music]
crap I'm
[Music]
oops this song though you know what put
this whole soundtrack on Spotify please
this soundtrack will make for some good
work music alright let's go catch the
arms it's like he's like Jax 700 K and
he's laughing at me oh I could not grab
him get two big body to grab oh no oh no
[Music]
all those it's awesome
I can calm love that Oh madam I'm so
used to chair you're like you trying to
- no
[Music]
okay I got him they use tell so
need to beat something up okay can you
give me Apple
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm actually really curious to see how
the battle mode is gonna be for the skin
because we're already discovering combos
we're already you know seeing juggle
States and wall bounces and stuff like
that so that's really fun I kind of
think of DFO a little bit no I failed
Floyd I failed him he was very slow uh
but he's cool he has like that little
arrow special that kind of bounce off
and then you can combo after it so
that's that's what cool also I'm gonna
try them again cuz I feel like you know
I played a lot with cherry and I played
Axl like a few runs as well so let's see
if this doesn't go well though oh oh
atabrine check out my Blitzcrank quick
spells
I have armor like a hit of art
[Music]
useful because it takes health to use
this way but I hit him immediately
afterwards so I kinda we want to get all
that back which is cool oh you've got
irises colors Oh
Oh No
oh my goodness I kind of knew that was
gonna happen the second that I did it Oh
[Music]
I still think cherries my Oh No
Cheerios my favorite so far yeah I tried
to hide stripes
LM like what that thing pretty
kickthrough thud I feel heavy with those
guys isn't there a skater character Oh
actually I know this is it a character
that I haven't unlocked yet that might
come maybe with the end of the story
we're all eating the box yeah
[Music]
glass and beauty oh this guy like Bob
literally get off your butt oh oh oh no
oh no Big Ben oh no you better stop
laughs and I mean who knew Oh Papa died
again this
[Music]
no not you not you
[Music]
I do like boys though so far oh yeah so
I can literally do my Apple Apple the
day he does more damage but you
trade-off speed yeah I can fill that for
sure
I just gotta be patient use my spacing
phone um Oh No
[Music]
this guy behind me with
[Music]
it's like I'm not gonna reach it if you
guys play League of Legends sounds like
set pull two enemies smack them into
each other this guy no this isn't fair
oh all right I'm going back to che I'm
sad I'm sad I'm cherry she's my girl
he's slow but his hits are crucial yeah
I could see that like my hips were
hurting compared to like I'm doing full
combos with this character alright
that's great actually
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh Oh
[Music]
oh boy
[Music]
he ate that no we got this all right I
think I had already lost a life by the
time I got to this point with Floyd
cherry is more your style of play yeah
totally
she's just a little bit fast to go she
has like a lot of really cool stuff for
invincibility move right there is
actually really good because it's like
and I especially like in situations like
this where I will I ran right into it
[Music]
Rob I know he's winding up for it all
right
I think Shari is one of the new
characters actually Oh
[Music]
laughing at
[Music]
how better
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
I ran into it sapphire no no no
[Music]
okay crap
[Music]
oh I grab somebody I didn't realize that
I was I find my stuff
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
all right whoop
[Music]
ah
[Music]
he ordered my
right
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh yes chicken never been so
happy for some chicken oh one oh she's
like bison and poisons all mixed
together I'm loving it
she is she is looking so fabulous Oh
[Music]
well oh my gosh he's just constantly
armored I guess oh okay
this invincibility I listen I traveled
lion help Louis is he powered up because
she's still here
I see
[Music]
out Positano
[Music]
I'm really digging her design Oh Nora
Nora dream
oh oh I'm always snacking me
[Music]
[Music]
Oh God that whip are you kidding me
alright it's fine it's fine I didn't
know what to expect now I know what to
expect I mean I'm just saying I see the
resemblance of these characters Oh was I
just not for it
[Music]
this guy in his anti ears
oh I tried to be fancy on them right
there
rap oh how many times am I gonna do that
yeah
[Music]
right
[Music]
never see much smashing
[Music]
set that freaking barrel man Oh No
[Music]
who is this on switch
I'm actually not 100% sure now I think I
think Sheree's my character perjurer
I've tried everyone now so far oh he
should not be this fast I'm Jessie
Oh No
[Music]
I can't know and then I'm throwing on
accident too he's almost bet he's just
go back
[Music]
[Music]
he pairs
[Music]
[Music]
now get over here
hello alright depth-perception release
day is tomorrow as far as night
[Music]
that knife
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
I'm gonna die
[Music]
he's actually waiting for tomatoes oh I
thought I was close enough to hit them
bull
you got me you got me you got me crap
are you gonna my gonna play on a joy con
I can't feel like so far I like how it
feels on arcade stick actually because
there are some combos that I'm doing
another fighting game esque you know I'm
doing like jab jab jab jab jab
forward forward alright xxx jump X
forward forward X like these are actual
fighting game come right there that is
legit I didn't come you see in 2d
fighters I don't have to worry about not
being on the same horizontal plane as
the bad guys because it's 2d fighter so
you know I'm struggling no I can do
don't you lady kick through I couldn't
do it
so that's nuts
[Music]
oh yeah like kicks guy oh no oh no
get over here I don't like the back
throw ha no
[Music]
crap like I'm the IV Gelbart get over
here
you do
[Music]
[Music]
NoHo this guy gonna be the death of me
literally
[Music]
all right we're gonna try more back
throws
I mean I'm fumbling on fightsticks a
night train yeah
[Music]
No so I buy these with - and then press
exit automatically counts as a forward
forward X like it stores the input the
entire time which is really interesting
oh I swear I never see that guy behind
me every time
save that apples
nah um oh my goodness I should have
picked up the Apple I wanted to save it
it's so in a way okay dang it I should
have picked it up I should
[Music]
[Music]
oh I try to throw up
[Music]
[Music]
you know hub
I'll meet up back up
he is not
[Music]
crap so I kind of hard
[Music]
and erosion down move where they get
enough time to set up Oh chicken okay
oh man only one life wrap them up say
bang gonna crash
no I don't want to throw her I don't
[Music]
No
[Music]
wait I think I'm a plumber ready first
[Music]
Oh chickens
[Music]
[Music]
the home
[Music]
a beer oh oh hey that's our wherever she
loved me
[Music]
[Music]
alright you know Viera Norah
get over here no wait listen huh if Nora
kills me right now oh my god Nora please
[Music]
plus but we didn't yeah what's the
bottle for I had the same question
uh-huh
I had the same question um apparently
you had just crack it and then you shank
him with it but um she whooped me so
like I couldn't do either of those
things very well but we got her all
right for coming close to the end of our
time here for the stream i'ma try and
get a little bit more of a stage in here
she's definitely female
bison shadaloo all the way
this is what poison would look like if
she took over shadaloo the old pier this
is supposed to be New York this is out
tomorrow actually you guys so oh I like
this office there looking like Matt was
it bad movie madness get over here
[Music]
Thank You Daniel I'm actually having a
blast of game right now and I'm not
necessarily great and that's be months
but this actually oh cool it's like oh
wait that I died we're falling in there
[Music]
and oh I was about to be high for my
hands here and then the other girl came
out of nowhere
[Music]
chicken knuckle yeah hold that
oh I died oh I was about to behave
[Music]
[Music]
No
[Music]
now the back row is pretty good because
it does like some impact damage to
straight threw me off the stage what is
this old caliber Calabro Apple some
money no yo she's she backhanded me I'm
hurting how's the game well Randall I
think this game is pretty good oh snap
the arcade
[Music]
I'm having a lot of fun with it nope
[Music]
now
[Music]
oh god he's I slid off the map he slid
and knock me off the map
and I'm about to die oh my oh my
goodness
all right I'm gonna try again oops I
didn't want to change Derek here though
got a few more minutes on this trip I'm
having so much fun right now
[Music]
[Music]
and I convinced ability to alright must
abuse back throw more oh no oh I didn't
even know she was there oh I tried to
knock them both off the stage
what what
[Music]
okay that's our oh that's really good
[Music]
No
no fear
oh it's so good oh no
[Music]
all right well you guys we've found the
answer and it's all in the back roads
it's all in the park
oh I thought I was gonna vote and the
fact I hit two people at once what's the
bathro follow-up is all right we've got
two special moves now you got a big
little bat
[Music]
[Music]
can't throw that can't throw three dudes
running at you with a knife okay oh sure
it's all char
[Music]
mashing nope oh come on dude
I just wanted to hit a home run oh okay
well you know what I got I got one of
them but I struck out oh wait yo I'm
sorry sir
[Music]
nope
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
ah there we go
[Music]
oh my
[Music]
whoa this guy chicken chicken okay wait
I have super moves I have super moves oh
don't fall up really that yeah yeah how
to make my own sound effects real quick
all right
this is really fun
[Music]
yep
get away huh oh thank you for sliding
[Music]
you write those books let's go Oh God
to match all of the special news all
right oh man I am fueling this game
right now oh hey stell absolutely
anything
Oh Mike you can catch of a Corolla - oh
no you never engage a bathro - huh
what did I say
[Music]
Oh get over here
[Music]
her super looks really cool
[Music]
ow okay I'll save that chicken
now that I have seen the weight of this
I grab her out of whatever she was out
about to do the fire I got a new life
all right lips oh crap oh crap
she called booed me into the missile
what a god hold up no yo she's so cool
though wait hold up Oh
[Music]
yo cut it out oh my god I'm about the
boss nope No
[Music]
all right I still got one more life here
[Music]
no no
no I get over here
Oh interesting Oh No
[Music]
nah oh she solo No
no ghetto there no you are not gonna hit
me with this freaking Gallic Stumbo
right now
wait this is she still dead you're so
dead it girls de D all right we got her
even though
oh she was last one okay okay cherry is
the girl back throw is the best and I
love this all right you guys that we're
actually overtime now by a few minutes
but that was super super fun and this is
out tomorrow if you guys are interested
I had an absolute blast and I'm actually
going to be playing more of this
I've been thank you the whole time and
that's been really really fun but you
know if you don't have an arcade stick
this works on keyboard and controller as
well so you know all up to you guys for
me personally sorry kids stick feels
really comfortable and it's really fun
and doing the combos is really really
fun too so thank you guys so much for
tuning in and don't forget every weekday
at 2 p.m. Pacific time is when we're in
love with a gamespot live catch us and
our UK team is actually doing live
streams on Tuesday and Thursday as well
so lots of live streams and Let's Plays
and games and chillin so hopefully you
guys will come back next time and hang
out thanks for watching and have a good
one you guys
[Music]